danica
is with us in fort lauderdale florida
hey donica how are you
hi dave hi rachel thank you so much for
taking my call today
sure what's up so my husband and i
um we're on baby step two we recently
welcomed our first
child or baby girl four weeks ago yay
thank you so we are our household income
is 142
000 and we have debt um a debt balance
of 148 000 um
we throughout the pregnancy this year we
actually
were still we were saving for the
arrival of our baby but we were also
paying off that we paid off about 30
thousand
um but we were wondering should we
sell our house um in order to kind of
speed up the debt payoff process the 148
does that include your home
it does not what is the 148 what kind of
debt is 148
um 109 000 of that is student loans and
the rest is consumer debt
one car loan and credit card how much is
the car
the car is 9 500 we got rid of one car
that's our this is the only car that we
have right now
[Music]
and you paid off 30 000 so far we did
yeah
thank god that took we started off our
payoff journeys uh january 2nd
of this year and we stopped uh last
month
we had her we had victoria a month ago
so yeah
we stopped in the last month or so to
kind of get situated
okay how much would you get from the
house if you sold it
um the balance is about 212 000 we're
hoping that we can sell it for a little
over 300
um maybe 300 maybe maybe 305.
okay around 75. yeah you like the house
we we are grateful for it um
we don't see ourselves staying here for
longer than two more years
honestly but we we are grateful for it
but we we would have somewhere to go
um our parents they have a couple extra
rooms in their in their home
so um we were wondering should we make
this large sacrifice we would be willing
to
if it means that we can you know pay off
our debt and
get onto you know okay so i answer
questions on this show by what would i
do if i woke up in your shoes knowing
what i know about getting out of debt
and how it leads to peace freedom all
that kind of stuff
okay right um and so
here's the way i would map it out if i
were you guys and that way you get a
real clear picture
of the trade-off number one you are not
in a position you need to move in with
your parents i would not do that
so if you sell you're gonna rent okay
that's what i would do okay you have a
new baby you have a good life
you make 142 000 a year you don't need
to be in your mama's basement
built-in built-in babysitter though but
it will keep going
i think we're picking up three of them
in the morning okay
anyway the uh um so the uh
uh anyway let's map it out if you sell
the house if you don't sell the house
okay okay if you don't sell the house i
think you're on a 45
to a 50 000 a year
debt reduction beans and rice rice and
beans
which puts you out of debt and somewhere
around three years from today
okay and i did that based on thirty
thousand done in nine months and you
were pregnant
yeah okay so now things are going to be
normalized a little bit you can cut this
this lifestyle down to nothing you can
just have one singular focus babies here
and that is for three years fifty
thousand dollars a year and you are done
okay okay uh and that's going to be
three very long very tough
years because you are going to have no
freaking life
during those three years you're right
okay
that's that's possibility number one
possibility number two is
you sell the house and you still have
a year to get out of debt while you're
renting
and then you're going to start saving to
repurchase
so if it takes three years to get out of
staying there
and it's three years before you're ready
to buy again
even though you sold in our debt free
that's what i would look that's what i
would weigh out okay
okay and so and so then you can also
reach out there and say
seven years from today if i go this way
this is where i'll be
if i go that way this is where i'll be
and seven years from today you're gonna
be in a different house anyway you told
me that
right seven years from today you're
gonna be debt-free
either way yes and seven years from
today
you will have either sold this house and
been a renter for a little while and
then saved up and bought the house
or you will have had this house and you
will sell it it will be worth more
five years from today when you sell it
and move into the seven year house
right so so there's not a right or wrong
here that's what you're saying
either way you're gonna get there yeah
and i think for you guys i mean donald
since you
i mean i we talked to some people and
they're like no no i'm in my dream home
oh should we sell it and it's like this
like sadness i mean it's just
terrible you know that you know that
departing with that house but you've
already kind of emotionally detached
from it you're like oh we'll be out
probably three years
so almost the emotional side it may be
easier just to just to go and sell it
move out
accelerate that debt-free journey and
then save up and then pay
pay for another house later for that
down payment but again
it neither one's right or wrong i
honestly think mathematically seven
years from today you're going to be in
about the same place either way
okay i see it the way i laid that out so
i don't care mm-hmm
uh it's kind of crazy but here's what i
rachel did pick up on okay
you already sold one car you said we'll
sell something else now i'm ready to
sell the house
it's like you guys already get out of
debt there's this i'm selling everything
right yeah and that's you communicating
that to us this is the way your
spirit's working right now and so uh
that's what rachel picked up on and
she's got yourself in the house for that
reason
right right but but mathematically i
think you're okay so i think you just
have to sit down and weigh out
uh but i would personally i would not
advise you
making this kind of money with a brand
new baby i don't think you need to be in
your mama's house
okay i just don't think it's necessary
to accomplish these goals
that is a and the advancement of these
goals
is so small due to that decision
that it's definitely not worth it in my
mind okay
yeah i i we did have some reservations
about that
um because if we rent we would probably
be spending the same amount
that we're paying on on our market you
would pay 1500 a month for our mortgage
we were probably going to spend the same
amount here in florida yeah
you might even have a little better
house um too
that's possible you might move up a
little bit if you did that i don't know
get out here's another thing you can do
that'll help you with the decision is
gather real facts not concepts
go shopping for rentals this weekend
it may make you throw up and you say i'm
staying in my house
or it may make you go my god i can rent
that for 250 bucks oh my god i'm selling
this house you know
and so uh i don't know i don't want the
complaint marketplace you're in but
sometimes when you put real facts
on your ideas your ideas don't have the
shine anymore
it's so true though like the facts take
the emotion out very quickly
right it's like you can kind of dream up
this whole thing and then you go
actually see
now this is literally what will happen
you're like oh wow okay and it does it
helps make the decision yeah like ouch
ouch ouch